president erdogan arriving in Vilnius
for last-minute talks on Sweden's
membership of NATO turkey has blocked
its entry for well over a year and
before he departed from Istanbul the
Turkish leader seemed to lay out a new
condition
we say open tookie's way to the European
Union first then as we previously did
for Finland we'll pave the way for
Sweden as well I expressed this to Mr
Biden last night and I have to underline
it again in Vilnius
we expect a visit from Mr Putin next
month if this visit to Turkey takes
place then we will also discuss the
Black Sea grain deal in our face-to-face
meetings that presents a new headache
for NATO leaders and for its Secretary
General Yen stoltenberg I support
turkey's Ambitions to become a member of
the European Union at the same time we
need to remember that what we agreed in
Madrid uh was a specific list of
conditions that Sweden has to meet to be
a full member of the alliance and Sweden
has met these conditions in addition to
the eve of summit talks with Tokyo and
Sweden behind the scenes they've also
been frantic negotiations on what NATO
leaders should say about President
zelenska's demands that his country be
given a clear and concrete path for it
to join the alliance the recent decision
by the Biden Administration to send
cluster Munitions to Ukraine has also
been the cause of much unease among
allies two-thirds of whom have signed
the international treaty Banning their
use a former NATO official says despite
all the difficulties the Allies must
Project Unity because the coming months
are key to deciding the outcome of the
war we're now in July the summer months
are going fast winter will arrive very
quickly so I do think yes the ukrainians
will need to show some kind of major
breakthroughs by August or by September
security for this Summit is extremely
tight NATO is brought in extra resources
here at Vilnius airport there are 12
Patriot batteries operated by the German
air force Lithuania has a border with
Russia and its border with the Russian
Ally Belarus is just over 30 kilometers
away James Bays Al Jazeera Vilnius